[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente por primera vez el censo de
mexico cuantificó a los más de 2
millones de afrodescendientes que viven
en el país hasta ahora no se tenían
datos sobre la población afro mexicana
hablamos con una de ellas
[Música]
y donald trump regresó el exmandatario y
su primera gran aparición pública desde
que dejó la casa blanca durante un
encuentro conservador en florida y dejó
la puerta abierta a ser candidato
presidencial en 2024 y todas estas
videollamadas durante la pandemia han
creado una oportunidad para los
cirujanos plástikos las operaciones se
incrementaron hasta en un 50% para
algunos médicos en eeuu en el último año
y vamos de inmediato a méxico por
primera vez en la historia del país el
censo nacional que se realiza cada 10
años incluyó en 2020 la opción de
definirse como afro mexicano como
resultado se contabilizó en 25 millones
de personas a los integrantes de esa
comunidad es decir el 2 por ciento de la
población total hasta ahora no había
datos sobre el número de población afro
mexicana sólo existía una encuesta de
2015 del instituto nacional de
estadística y geografía según la cual
eran 13 millones de personas lo que
significa que los afromexicanos serán
excluidos de apoyos al no pertenecer a
una etnia determinada según la
constitución y precisamente hablamos con
jessica este moreno ella es una
escritora de obras de teatro y afro
mexicana nos contó cómo es ser afro en
mexico
bueno ser afrodescendiente en mexico es
pasar por un proceso de invisibilización
de no reconocimiento porque toda esta
historia negra pues ha sido negada ha
sido negada en los libros de historia ha
sido negada en la cotidianidad y ha sido
negada y violentada a partir de pues
acciones como el racismo la
discriminación la separación entonces
pues era fue tendiente en mexico es
estar en una lucha constante día a día
no desde el proceso mismo del auto
reconocimiento no de asumirse como tal
hasta afrontar todas estas violencias
día a día y eso ya es un proceso de
lucha y un proceso
que pues quienes lo decidimos así
después de conseguir todas estas luchas
pues se vuelve un orgullo se vuelve un
orgullo pero pues es un lugar al que se
llega después de un proceso largo y
doloroso
y desde acá estar moreno también nos
explicó que sigue en la lucha por los
derechos de la comunidad afro en mexico
bueno pues para empezar como el primer
paso ya se dio aunque ese reconocimiento
en el censo poblacional y además pues es
la primera vez que se hace no en mexico
entonces bueno ya ese es un primer paso
porque al saberse la población
afrodescendiente no va a ser evidente en
las cifras
entonces ya se pueden empezar a trabajar
políticas públicas y estas políticas
públicas tienen que ir dirigidas también
a las mujeres a la comunidad comunidad
hereje
afrodescendiente no y cada una debe de
tener sus condiciones específicas que
tienen que incluirse en estas políticas
creo que lo que sigue es reunirnos como
afrodescendientes como con los
representantes de las comunidades con
las autoridades también para ir creando
estas políticas y bueno por otra parte
pues en el arte no el arte es una
herramienta importantísima porque es a
través del arte que se da a conocer esta
historia que antes estaba negada
y también se da a conocer cuáles son las
condiciones en las que viven ahora las
comunidades afrodescendientes no
solamente en los pueblos sino también de
los que vivimos en las ciudades por
ejemplo no y cuáles son esas condiciones
qué es lo que se hace falta y el arte es
una herramienta que nos sirve muchísimo
para esta visibilización
y vamos a el salvador para revisar otras
noticias de las américas esta semana las
elecciones municipales del salvador
dejaron al partido nuevas ideas del
presidente en allí bukele con la mayoría
lo que genera preocupación por la
concentración del poder del mandatario
tanto por parte de la oposición como de
la comunidad internacional que
consideran podría representar el fin de
la institucionalidad en el país
centroamericano
y la fiscalía colombiana pidió el cierre
del caso en contra del expresidente
álvaro uribe vélez por supuesto fraude y
soborno de testigos sin embargo el
proceso aún tiene un largo camino por
delante antes de cerrarse pues si alguna
de las partes no lo acepta podría llegar
a la corte suprema de justicia
y en argentina la ex presidenta cristina
fernández quien ahora es vicepresidenta
acusó a los magistrados de ayudar al ex
presidente mauricio macri a obtener la
victoria en las elecciones de 2015 y se
declaró una perseguida por el poder
judicial para rechazar el proceso en su
contra por presuntas irregularidades en
la venta del llamado dólar futuro cuando
era mandataria
[Música]
vamos a eeuu donald trump dejó la puerta
abierta a ser candidato en 2024 en su
primer discurso desde que abandonó la
presidencia siguió sin reconocer la
derrota en las urnas en 2020 y en su
lugar dijo que podría vencer a los
demócratas una vez más sin embargo
descartó que lo fuera a hacer a través
de un nuevo partido como se había
especulado tram cuenta con el apoyo de
un vasto sector de la población y lo
sabe por eso se mostró como la figura
más fuerte del partido republicano de
cara a retomar el control del congreso
en las elecciones de medio término y por
supuesto en las presidenciales de 2024
su discurso se basó principalmente en
atacar al presidente joe biden quien no
lleva ni 100 días en el poder
[Aplausos]
de hecho como ustedes saben ellos acaban
de perder la casa blanca
pero quién sabe quién sabe
yo podría incluso decidir ganarles por
tercera vez
aún está por verse si contaría con el
apoyo total del partido republicano
considerando la escandalosa forma en la
que abandonó la presidencia negándose a
reconocer su derrota en las elecciones
de noviembre de 2020 y procesado en el
senado por incitar a la insurrección
durante el asalto del capitolio el 6 de
enero y si se están preguntando si puede
aspirar a pesar de haber sido el único
presidente en la historia de eeuu en
haber sido judicial izado dos veces en
el legislativo la respuesta es sí pues
fue declarado no culpable y no se aprobó
una medida adicional para impedírselo y
en cuanto a su fórmula la prensa
estadounidense ha reportado que podría
ser su hija ivanka
también durante su discurso de regreso
trump hizo un llamado a la base más
radical del partido sus más fervientes
seguidores y de un discurso muy similar
al que utilizó cuando lanzó su campaña
en 2016 volvió a decir que los migrantes
que llegan a eeuu desde el sur son según
sus palabras violadores criminales y
narcotraficantes
trabajamos muy duro ellos los
interceptan toman su nombre quizás son
asesinos quizás son violadores quizás
son traficantes de drogas toman su
nombre y los dejan entrar en nuestro
país nosotros hacíamos lo contrario no
sólo no los dejábamos entrar en nuestro
país sino que los de volvíamos al suyo
se volverán guardas que de adentro
y desde que llegó a la casa blanca- joe
biden está determinado a dar un giro en
las políticas más controversiales de su
antecesor por ejemplo entregó al
congreso un proyecto de reforma
migratoria y pidió acelerar las
solicitudes de asilo y terminar con la
política de separación de familias en
ciudad juárez del lado mexicano de la
frontera las solicitudes han empezado a
ser gradualmente tramitadas veamos el
siguiente informe
esperan un chequeo de salud para poder
dirigirse al punto de control fronterizo
y finalmente poner pie en suelo
estadounidense cuando yo llegué rápido
la forma de legalizar mi papel y
comenzar a trabajar tras la firma de
varias órdenes ejecutivas por parte del
presidente yo bailé en el pasado mes
varios cientos de migrantes pudieron
pasar desde méxico hacia eeuu su
proyecto de reformar el sistema
migratorio pone fin a una serie de
medidas de la administración trump que
mantiene a los solicitantes de asilo del
lado mexicano
aquí en ciudad juárez quienes
registraron están siendo gradualmente
llamados para continuar su proceso en el
lado norte de la frontera
tenían mucha ansiedad antes de lo que
iba a pasar pero
estaban cruzando el alivio hasta obvio
en sus caras pero es un proceso lento
por ahora la gran mayoría de los 25.000
solicitantes de asilo cuyos casos siguen
bajo examinación están varados en méxico
bengoa pero siempre viven con miedo
porque alguien no es un lugar para uno
aquí es un lugar peligroso
washington dice que el proceso se
acelerará pronto particularmente en los
casos de los menores separados de sus
familias en la frontera y que están en
centros de detención las imágenes de los
niños durmiendo en el piso en espantosas
jaulas impactaron al mundo en 2017
convirtiéndose en un símbolo de las
condiciones inhumanas dentro de los
centros de detención alrededor de 100
familias han sido reunidas en las
últimas semanas y vamos a eliminar la
crueldad de la administración pasada y
vamos a reconstruir nuestro sistema de
solicitudes blas y los hornets en hong
kong
estamos diciendo no vengan estamos
diciendo no vengan ahora porque vamos a
poder entregarles un proceso ordenado y
seguro
más pronto que sea posible es cuerpo y
espacio lo que marcó un giro en la casa
blanca y que se prevé va a facilitar los
intercambios entre joe biden y su
homólogo mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador como se evidenció en su primera
reunión virtual el lunes
y los que quizás son los beneficiarios
menos probables de la pandemia son los
cirujanos plásticos un informe dice que
ha habido un incremento de pacientes
debido a la sobreexposición en zoom
otras personas están tomando ventaja del
confinamiento y del teletrabajo para
esconder sus vendajes o cicatrices
veamos
voy a mirar sus incisiones y ver cómo
está sanando la primera vez que jasón
youngers se hizo una cirugía fue en
octubre de 2020 optó por un
levantamiento facial y de párpados no
soportaba verse a sí mismo durante las
videoconferencias es algo nuevo tener
que ver su propia cara durante horas y
días y no hay mucho que hacer con la
buena luz ni los ángulos te descubres
por primera vez en su vez y te das asco
desde que se incrementó la frecuencia de
las videollamadas este cirujano notó un
aumento dentro del 50 y el 60 por ciento
de los procedimientos estéticos en
number one persistió de equipo de
benjamín cambie el procedimiento número
uno que la gente está buscando es la
elevación de sus párpados o de su cuello
es decir de por qué viene esto colgando
la cámara o que se ve como una doble
papada otros están aprovechando que no
estarán bajo la vista de sus colegas
para someterse al bisturí está
publicista se recuperó en casa sin tener
que tomar vacaciones tras una cirugía de
senos estaba tentada a volver al
quirófano haití depende de que creo que
la pandemia en general le ha dado tiempo
a la gente para reflexionar y ocuparse
de las cosas que quería hacer hace mucho
tiempo dejan fairground su cirujana
washington trabaja duro para cumplir con
la demanda los pacientes dicen no puedo
viajar no puedo ver a mi familia esto es
algo que puedo hacer para sentirme mejor
conmigo mismo y tener mayor confianza
ella ha visto el número de clientes de
su agenda multiplicarse desde el
principio de la pandemia lo que
significa que al parecer trabajar desde
casa todavía no le ha puesto fin al
culto de la apariencia
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho y sigan viendo france24
[Música]